[music]
goo I found you brother
Thank you for
your hard work Hey, where
are you?
I was on the edge, but I
jumped down from here and headed for the lower exit
[laughter] From
this height to the sea, she's the princess of Zahad.
I wonder if you're running in the middle of the
sea Is your dive from this height strong until morning?
No
, you just have to wait there.
[MUSIC] If
I remember correctly, the amount of God's water is limited in this exam.
Even if you turn
off the light, you can buy it at Shinsui Aura.
You hid the demon in the University of Tokyo that you copied.
If you get
squashed, what would happen if you tried to get on top of the lighthouse?
You're seriously going to end your life
[music]
[applause]